and we call it
the ipad
apple's ipads have been using lcd
technology ever since the original ipad
and even the new mini led ipad pro
models are still technically using lcd
panels so it should make us wonder why
apple has refused to switch to oled over
the years and when they'll actually be
making the switch so in this video i'm
not only going to answer those questions
but i'm going to delve into the latest
rumors of how apple is finishing out the
releases of their final lcd and mini led
ipad pro models while setting in stone
their master plan for switching to oled
displays across their entire ipad lineup
and i actually think that this is quite
genius so without further ado let's
begin with some brand new rumors we got
over the weekend concerning apple's
upcoming ipad air 5 refresh coming this
spring in either march or april
according to mack otakara the new air
will be getting the a15 bionic chip the
12 megapixel ultra wide selfie camera
with center stage support optional 5g
and quad led true tone flash which is
all very obvious because those are the
features that the ipad mini 6 recently
was upgraded with so it only makes sense
for the ipad air to get them as well
especially since the current air is more
expensive than the mini now apart from
those obvious updates makatakara says
that we could expect the new ipad air to
finally get an upgrade to feature quad
speakers instead of the current dual
speaker situation on the ipad air 4
which is actually pretty weird because
it has four speaker grilles but only two
of them have speakers behind them so it
makes sense for the new one to use all
four grilles but other than that they
also mentioned that the ipad air could
be getting the same dual camera setup as
the current ipad pro models have and
maybe even the lidar scanner and all of
this would actually make sense because
apple has a history of bringing their
best technology to the ipad pro first
and then slowly trickling those features
down to the rest of the ipads starting
with the ipad air then the mini and then
finally to the budget ipad like for
example dylan dkt on twitter just
confirmed that the upcoming 10th gen
budget ipad will have a very minimal
update later this year with optional 5g
connectivity and a new a14 chip with it
being the last model before the big
redesign planned for next year but the
very interesting leaks we gotta get into
are the ones for the 2022 ipad pro
models first of all we're expecting both
the 11 and 12.9 inch models to get the
new m2 chip which will debut in the
redesigned macbook air and that will
obviously be much faster than the a15
chip that's going into the upcoming ipad
air 5. but on top of that we're also
expecting apple to give us a huge design
change by adding max safe wireless
charging to the back of the new ipad pro
models potentially within a new larger
apple glass logo which i recently made a
video on and probably even a new magsafe
magic keyboard case and going further we
also got some rumors of apple upgrading
the camera system to match the triple
camera setup we currently have on the
iphone 13 pro lineup which is probably
why the new air is getting the old dual
camera design and then the final rumor
that makes total sense to me is that the
11 inch ipad pro would now finally get
the mini led display that you can
currently only get on the 12.9 inch
model and with that i personally expect
the base price to jump up to 899 dollars
instead of the current 799 price and
then with that said this finally brings
us to apple's oled master plan and how
they could kick-start the transition and
brace yourselves because this is about
to get interesting but first i need to
quickly explain why apple has been
avoiding oled for so long first of all
oled has always been pretty expensive
and there used to be a lot of problems
with display burn-in after a few years
and other issues like oled displays just
not being that bright but now all the
technology has been improving and things
like color accuracy display angles color
shift and burn-in are drastically
improved compared to previous
generations so it seems like apple might
finally be ready to make the switch so
let's get into how they're gonna do this
the rumors of the very first oled ipad
began back in march of 2021 with digi
times claiming that an oled 10.9 inch
ipad would come in early 2022
which we know right now is not happening
anymore but the interesting point is
that they said it'll have a 10.9 inch
display which can only be the ipad air
since the pro models start at 11 inches
now in the same month of march ming chi
quo came out and confirmed that the ipad
air would adopt oled in 2022
with mini led remaining exclusive to the
ipad pro models because of the
advantages of higher brightness and then
in june the elec basically said the same
thing a new ipad air with oled in 2022
but then finally in july the very
reliable ross young came out and said
that the first 10.9 inch oled ipad would
not be coming until 2023
so it looks like it's been delayed for
sure so with all that said i can agree
that it makes total sense for the ipad
air to get an oled display next year and
since the ipad air is usually on a one
to one and a half year update cycle i
expect this oled ipad air to be released
in the fall of 2023 but then everything
got a little bit more confusing because
we also got some recent reports of a new
oled display for apple's ipad pro models
which could go from 120 hertz down to 10
hertz refresh rate just like the new
iphone 13 pro models can and over the
past week the elec has again confirmed
that this new panel would be launching
in 2024
using samsung display as the
manufacturer and just yesterday et news
reported that lg is also preparing to
supply oled panels for the ipad by 2024
and what makes all of this really
confusing is that we have conflicting
release dates for conflicting ipad
models but i think that i've finally
figured everything out and i figured out
how apple could make this transition as
smooth as possible my prediction is that
in the fall of 2023
apple's gonna release a new ipad air
with an oled display that will have much
better contrast levels compared to the
current lcd models however it will not
be better than the mini led ipad pro
models because the oled panel on the
ipad air is going to be limited to
around 500 to 600 nits of brightness as
well as only having a 60hz refresh rate
but either way the oled panel is still
going to be a nice upgrade over the
current lcd air so it's going to justify
a price increase but then around half a
year later in the spring of 2024 i
expect apple to release a new 12.9 inch
ipad pro model with an even better oled
panel because that's actually what
digitimes reported on way back in march
of last year and if you're wondering
what i mean by an even better oled panel
this brings us to a report from the
elect back in november where they claim
that the future ipad pro and macbook pro
models would feature ultra bright double
stack oled displays so they'll
essentially have two of the same display
panel stacked on top of each other to
literally double the brightness so that
the ipad pro models will still support
real hdr with at least a thousand or
maybe 1200 nits of brightness and the
even bigger benefit is that the oled
technology would mean that the current
display blooming issues with the mini
led displays would completely go away
while also enabling them to support
hertz promotion like the current models
have so it would basically create the
ultimate oled display with no
compromises and that would of course
warrant a price increase as it would be
a much better display compared to the
ipad air model which will only have a
single oled panel limited in brightness
and refresh rate and then sometime in
2025 i expect the 11 inch ipad pro model
to get updated with that same new oled
display at a base price of 999
and then the ipad mini will adopt the
lower end oled display also probably in
2025 and then with that said probably a
full year after that sometime in 2026
the budget ipad will finally get the
oled display and then that's how i
expect apple's full oled ipad transition
to take place finishing up completely
within around three years time which
isn't bad at all so there you guys go
that's my take on apple's oled master
plan transition and if you totally
disagree with my thoughts on how apple
will implement oled on these ipads then
go ahead and comment down below but if
you enjoyed the video tap the like
button and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]